okay hello and welcome to pi data global
2021 my name is zachary i'm very happy
to be here and be your host for this
session i would like to now welcome
valentino and paul
um to this session and he and she will
talk about
um
the image classification in retail
lesson from the real world so let's move
the time to paul and frantina thank you
thanks for the introduction let me just
share my screen
so
i'm valentina and together with paul we
work at tesco and together we will talk
about image classification in retail
and the lessons that we learned by um
working in a real world
scenario
so at first
i mean in this presentation i'll
introduce a bit what we do in the data
science team at tesco um and then we
then talk about image classification and
we will focus mainly on how to generate
a data set that would represent the
real world problem that you're trying to
solve
and what are the challenges that you may
encounter because especially in deep
learning um people would
focus on like academic uh data sets so
the only part you would focus on is the
design
of the network and the architecture that
you would use but actually there is a
lot about the dataset generation when
you work on a
real world scenario
so the data science team um at tesco
essentially tesco is a
grocery company and we are in the united
kingdom and
central europe um it's the biggest
supermarket in uk so we have like more
than 3 000 stores and in the united
kingdom and more than 300 000 colleagues
and this is to say that um i mean the
volume generated
is quite big so also the data that we
have available
um is um
is not uh like it's quite a lot and um
so
being like the largest supermarket in
the uk um the data science team is quite
big and well established we are more
than 70
colleagues
and we are involved essentially in many
departments almost all the departments
in the
in the company um
we won't focus much about what we do but
um on saturday there is going to be a
presentation about uh the stack that we
use in the data science team tesco um so
if you are interested please attend that
talk now let's focus on the image
classification so for those of you who
are not familiar with it essentially um
the image classification is the problem
in which you have a set of images you
have a set of classes and for each image
you want to associate a class so as you
can see in here for example you would
have
some images you have you have some
classes in here and then you need to
label each image with a class
so these images are images of a checkout
where a person would scan
would scan a product
and so in this case for example
what would you see in this image we can
see that the person is scanning
um
a breadth
and then the next one if you look among
these classes the person is scanning
mango and so on
but of course we don't want to do this
manually but how can we do it
automatically
so one way is um
convolutional neural networks um in deep
learning so essentially you build a data
set where for each image you associate a
class and then you have this data set
and you provide this data set to a
convolutional neural network which will
learn
to classify those images so the image
will go through this neural network
which is composed of a lot of
convolutional layers and the objective
of each convolutional layer is to output
a feature
and at the end you would have a fully
connected layer which will output
the probability of this image to belong
to each of these classes so for example
in this case you have a mango and what
you expect the network to learn is that
you will have a low probability for each
of the classes except for the mango
class which would have probability close
to one
so what is the issue now the problem i
mean the
the work is
can be split into two stages the first
is
um build a data set that would be as
representative as possible of the
problem you are trying to solve and then
the second stage would be once you have
right the right data set then you want
to
choose the right network and train the
model in order to be able to classify
each image of this data set and then in
the end you will end up with a model or
a neural network
that will be able to classify the images
in your in your real uh scenario
so the first thing is you need lots of
labels and lots of images and now the
issue is how would you generate those
images you can go on like search
existing data sets but you won't find
that as it with checkouts for example
and so one way to do it is because we
are um
a supermarket we have uh checkouts and
the checkouts are able to generate some
logs that will say at this given time
stamp um this product was scanned and
the product is labeled with the barcode
which is called g10
and then you also have cameras on top of
the checkout
and each frame of the camera is
associated with a timestamp so you can
combine the two and then generate a
series of images that will have a
barcode as a label
now easy no you think fine i can
generate the data set automatically and
i don't need to spend much money
on people looking at images
unfortunately that's not really the case
and here is an example so let's say in
this case
a person has count an alcohol bottle
which you can see in here
and you extract like let's say five
seconds around
the scanning of the product but then you
can see all these images are going to be
labeled with the same barcode
can you see something
silly
so first of all is the empty checkout so
these two images are going to be labeled
as um with the same barcode but actually
they don't show anything and so this is
the first unanticipated situation that
you will encounter when you want to
build such a data set
then you would have another problem
which is the covert checkout so let's
look at this this will have also another
barcode
label however we only see like the heart
of a person so again we should be able
to find a way to say that we can't use
all these images as
part of our data set
and yet another issue is actually what
class are you going to associate these
two because yes you can say this is an
alcohol bottle but we can also see some
non-alcoholic bottles here so what are
we gonna say does it contain alcohol
bottle or non-alcoholic bottle and of
course all these things will impact the
performance of the model trained if we
had left all these um labels uh in the
data set
so these are not only the
unanticipated situations that you will
encounter
but let's say we have fruit for example
and now we want to classify bananas so
the one you can see here are bananas
fine we can label them as bananas and
then you also have bananas in a pack so
in a package like this but you can still
see they are bananas so that's fine but
then
what if you actually have them in here
could you say that this is a banana or
maybe looks like lettuce
and could you say that this is a banana
and again you need to remember that all
these images would end up with the label
banana
provided to the model when you train it
if you don't handle these cases
and then there is another issue so tesco
for example is um
[Music]
is targeting like less
usage of plastic so they introduce a
brown bug instead of plastic when you
buy loose products now let's say we want
to use the same um
the same approaches before when you have
the automated labeling then again this
might be labeled as apples but can you
really see that they are apples or it's
just like a brown bug so maybe the
solution would be to have a brown butt
class
but that cannot be generated
automatically
so
how do we improve all these labels one
way is
uh
let's use some human labelers and tell
them give them like present the pictures
say these are the classes you can choose
from
go on and label and refine the dataset
however it's not that simple because um
as you can see the you can come up with
a
quite um
not easy um set of rules
so it becomes um quite complicated
and then let's say we are the labelers
also we will encounter issues like this
so this image for example will be
labeled as occluded or empty because it
doesn't show
anything but actually it does show a
person scanning a barcode so is this
correct if we had labeled it as occluded
or empty and then the same here a person
is holding something under his hand
paul and i know because we have seen
plenty of these images that this is
either an avocado or an onion because
they easily roll on the checkout and
they can fall so you tend to cover them
with your hand to make them stable but
um
is this really an avocado could you say
that and same here you see an avocado or
a mango
and
for the other
images as well so even though it seems
that
image classification would be
an easy task actually there are a lot of
issues that you can already encounter
only at the beginning when you want to
generate the data set and we haven't
even
touched the part of the model trainings
um
this is another example where let's say
you have multiple images of the same
scum so a person is scanning something
and you get like an image for each like
second on so on and so in here are you
able to recognize this one most people
would say i have no idea what this
product is
but then
if i show this one i'm pretty sure
everyone would have an idea that this is
an alcohol bottle so even when you
present images to the labelers you need
to be careful on what you select and how
you select your data
and now i'll pass it into like to both
for other issues encountered
okay so when you're dealing with
real-world data sets
one problem that
is very common is that the data set the
data is very imbalanced so for example
here is an overview of some of the
classes that we had in our model
and you can see that there so this is a
logarithmic cloud and you can see there
like many other magnitudes between the
most common and the least common classes
so you have like a million images for
the most common class and then under a
thousand for the for the least common
one
and so that kind of makes it uh tricky
when you actually go to train a model
because the model might not learn very
much about the very uncommon classes so
there are standard ways of addressing
this you can oversample you can
undersample there are some papers that
say that over something actually works
quite well for image classification but
then you actually try to do that in the
real world and you have a huge imbalance
like here you can't really over sum
because if you try to over sample to get
everything to a uniform distribution
your data set would be so big that you
can't even train for one epoch
and then on the other hand if you're on
the sample
of course you're throwing a base on beta
so and what we found that worked the
best in our case was to use
undersampling but do it in a kind of
smart way where you try to throw away
data that's kind of similar to other
data that you already have in the in the
data set so for example if you have one
scan of product you take
only a few
images of that scan
for the less common classes
for the more common classes and all of
the images for the for the less common
ones so this is kind of what you can do
in order to create the distribution
that's easier for training on but then
you have another program because you're
training the model on one distribution
but then when you actually want to
deploy the model you know it will
encounter a different distribution that
might be the same like
distribution of the original training
set or it might again be quite different
depending on how you collect the data
so so you have to do something in order
to make the model uh work on the real
distribution and then also when you
evaluate your models and then you maybe
have multiple models you want to compare
them against each other you need to
decide how you want to evaluate them
like do you consider every class as
equally important even though some of
them maybe like maybe some products are
so rare that the model will only see
like one of them a weak and is it really
important the model is extremely
accurate in those
and but then also you might have
requirements from like a
like independent of the bait itself but
coming from business it tells you it's
very important that your model gets this
class right because it
actually means we have to i don't know
do an intervention or
inconvenience a customer or something
like that
so there's
many factors to kind of keep in mind and
now to come back to this second point to
that the distribution that you train the
model on might be different from the one
at test time
so there's a
so
if you assume that after you train a
model
that the probability is that the model
outputs like from the the last layer
which is a softmax in in a normal
classification case
the output is is kind of it looks like a
probability distribution like it sounds
to one you know it varies from zero to
one
um and if you assume that this is
actually a correctly calibrated
probability distribution that tells you
uh
like if the model says 0.8 that means 80
percent of the time it should be correct
so if you assume that's the case
then there's actually a nice way to
convert the model from one distribution
to another
so here on the in the graph on the right
you can see uh first at the training set
and we see in the training sets there's
mostly apples and then
pears and then a few less bananas
so this is the distribution we train on
so the model kind of expects to see more
apples than pears than bananas but then
at test time
we know maybe we
looked at some some logs or we know
something about how what happens in the
store we know that actually the model
will see fewer apples so the
distribution is quite different from the
training distribution and now if you
have a model trained on this training
set and you
apply it on some image and you get an
output like this so the model is very
assured that it's seeing an apple
then this might not actually be the
output that you want because in in the
in in the store at test time you expect
to see less apples maybe the model
should be less confident so what you
want is you want to kind of transform
this output to get a an output that's
kind of adapted to the real distribution
that you know is is their test time and
there's actually a very easy way to do
that and this just follows from bayes
theorem
which is that you can just rescale the
probabilities
uh
probabilities by the ratio of these two
distributions and then you have to
normalize again and then you get this
transformed output and that's actually
assuming that the original model was
well calibrated and this transforms on
with the two
and this is kind of nice because it
means that you can do this kind of under
something for example
to
to have a training set that's easier to
train on and then you can transform the
model to make it adapted to the actual
distribution you would see
a test time
but this kind of assumes that the model
is well calibrated in the first place
which is for for neural networks
i mean there's some indication that it's
sort of true but they're also often
quite over confident so you can't be
sure that the calibration is
uh
is that great
so and and if you assume that it's not
it's not well calibrated well then
instead of just having this ratio
between the two distributions
you can actually think about changing
all these parameters arbitrarily so you
have a
number of classes three parameters that
you can use to add that the model to any
any new distribution
and of course then the question becomes
how do you choose these parameters which
can be quite a few if you have a lot of
classes so you can think about doing
some kind of optimization or something
over these and if we go back now to an
easier problem which is just binary
classification there's kind of a similar
problem there if you want to classify
something into class a or class b you
have a model that outputs some value
between zero and one what you do is you
just set this threshold and depending on
where you set the threshold you will
have
more outputs on class a or more on class
b and you can adapt it to the
distribution and if you have two models
and you kind of want to compare them but
the thresholds might not be equivalent
between the two the what we often do but
it's just the standard thing to do is to
use a metric that's kind of independent
to this
to the setting of the threshold so for
example the area under the curve area
under the roc curve
and that's that's very nice because you
have just have this one number and you
don't don't have to worry about setting
thresholds and looking at how the
performance changes over this threshold
so it would be nice to have that also in
the multi-class setting
but it turns out that's actually quite
hard in the multicast setting and
there's
base multi-class versions of auc
which uh kind of sounds like they would
work but they actually don't like if you
do this rescaling that i mentioned
before then these metrics change that
are not independent and there's other
metrics like this uh mean average
precision that's similar to what's used
for object detection but that also
changes
uh when you
when you do this kind of recalibration
so from what i know there isn't really
any
standard metric that you can use that's
independent on this kind of
a complete
recalibration of the of the distribution
but that's a bit unfortunate but it
means you have to be quite careful when
evaluating uh different models and when
you have two models and one of them
looks better than the other you have to
check that this is actually still true
after you calibrate the models
to make them perform better in your test
distribution
so now let's go to a different problem
which is also
has something to do with distributions
but in this case it's about not the
distribution of the classes but the
distribution of your input data
so this is uh
this is just a problem of generalization
basically
and the
the the main point is that if you have
two models that perform that are trained
on some training set and then test it on
some unseen test set and they they
perform similarly well on the on the
test set that doesn't mean that they are
equally good at generalizing the new
settings they did generalize to the test
set but if you now collect a new test
set in maybe a slightly different
setting one of the models might be a lot
better at adapting to that than the
other
and very early in our development we had
a situation like that where we had one
simple model which was just a couple of
convolutional layers very few parameters
and we just trained it from scratch and
we had another model which was based on
the
which was a transfer learning model
based on some standard model string on
imagenet which had a lot more parameters
and they both performed basically
exactly the same on the test sets that
we had and so we kind of thought maybe
we preferred a smaller model because
fewer parameters it's faster to run
but then we actually got so this is
kind of the images image at the top is
sort of the images we had for the
training and the test set but then a bit
later we got some new data from a
different store where
it looked very different like the image
at the bottom
and you can see well the lighting is
quite different but also like the
background is different and the sort of
kill
that stay in the background and it
turned out the transfer learning model
actually worked perfectly well on this
new data set so slightly worse than the
old one but still quite well
but the small just
simple model just didn't work at all so
you can see actually the prediction here
is the prediction of the same simple
model and they just said alcohol instead
of banana which is not
not correct at all
and so
you can do stuff like uh data
augmentation
changing brightness contrast so on and
that can help a bit but real world
effects can be quite subtle especially
when it's about like patterns in the
background instead of just uh
global shifts in color and brightness
and so on and there's this this recent
paper that i thought was quite
interesting and kind of
fits our experience as well and it
basically says that that's uh the way
you get robustness to out of
distribution samples is is to use a
model that has just seen a lot of images
during this training time and that might
be
a model that's pre-trained on a large
data set and then fine-tuning a
different task and as long as you don't
fine tune it until it forgets everything
it has ever seen as long as you you
don't fine-tune too much
then you actually get better robustness
than with a model that's only trained on
one specific task
and then
so this was kind of a kind of a simple
case of distribution shift where for a
human it's still very clear that this is
still a banana and it's just the
background that changes
you can have a bit more tricky
situations where the
the the thing that shifts in the
distribution is actually quite close to
what you're trying to detect
so for example here we had a model that
that's just supposed to tell us whether
there is a product in the image or not
so for example here these two images
would be no product because there's
there's till and then there's only some
some people but there's no product and
then on the right you have images that
should be classified as product because
you do still see people but then there's
also a little bit of a product peeking
through
so this is kind of the task the model is
supposed to do
but then we actually got images from a
new store and suddenly there was we saw
that the model always said there was a
product
and this was just because they put a
sticker on the till which you can see
here and while the sticker is it's not
the background of the till that the
model was used to and it's also not the
person so the model said it was a it was
a product yeah if there are questions i
guess yes okay so um i get a question
from philip
um i would like to know whether it would
be possible to adopt a classified
problem of a single cross classification
image problem into a multi-class single
image classification
image problem
the latter problem would
involve detecting different object in a
given image
yeah so that's something we did explore
but in the setting that we were looking
at like it's self checkout
there's almo there's mostly only a
single product feasible there's very few
cases where there's multiple products
and also for the multiple products we
don't have the labels so we would have
to like
uh
have human labelers label them so it's a
lot of effort so
for that reason we just focused on the
single scales
model
okay okay another question is could you
share like
on the data selection progress for human
classifiers
how
much data tesco classifies or it does
done
automatically
yeah so that's definitely an important
thing i mean mostly we used human human
label data as a test set to evaluate the
model so it was mostly uh
getting a representative sample of all
the classes and the different like
stores and checkouts that we have
because actually getting uh human labels
to label the training data is
you need a lot of labels for that so
it's the test that is the most important
okay
and another question from robert is that
of over sampling or under assembling
cannot you just read the back
pull grading error
inversely
yeah you you can you can do it you can
decide
you can wait just to use waiting instead
but then you still have the issue that
like in most batches you won't have a
sample from the from the from the under
on the represented classes so you train
the model a long time in one direction
and then at some point you get one
sample and you wait the error a lot
and then you just jump
you have a big jump uh in the weights
so i'm not sure if it would work as well
and also if you do for example if you do
over sampling every over sample image
will be augmented differently by the
data augmentation so that actually helps
it won't be exactly the same image
okay uh one more question from video
again how could uh one add additional
permanent
to the training model so that
so to enhance the detection accuracy
since those um parents did not have the
same 2d unlike structure that image have
um how could one add those permanent in
and and and architecture
yeah so i mean that's a nice part about
neural networks they're quite flexible
so you would you have the convolutional
layer stack which kind of gets you the
features from the image and then what
you could for example do is at the last
layer where you flatten all the
convolutional information into just a
single vector you could add some
additional entries which come from some
additional data
but i mean in our case you don't really
have that because
the point was to classify the product
from the image at all and at that point
we don't have any additional papers
okay last question can you briefly
explain that
the use case of the model and how good
it has to be
yeah so this was mostly uh
just an investigation of what we can do
with kind of data that's
that's available in tesco because we
already have the cameras and we wanted
to see
uh kind of what we can do for that and
for example
one use case would could be to improve
the customer experience at the till
against the yeah just make it make it
easier for the customer to check out
okay thank you our time is over clear
kindly move to the discussion this night
or get a ton
thank you
paul and valentino um we talk and for
being part of the pi data global 2021
thank you so much
thanks cheers